the death of Superman lives what
happened is a documentary film directed
by Jon Schnepp now you guys may know who
that is he used to be on AMC movie talk
which has now turned into Collider movie
talk I've personally met him we've done
a few YouTube shows together in the past
I was on the masters of the web panel at
San Diego comic-con with him and that's
where I had a chance to pick up his film
at his booth at comic-con I was very
intrigued by this movie for a couple of
reasons for one she naps a really nice
guy we got along really well and I love
the fact that someone who's on YouTube
talking about movies got to make a film
that's very inspiring to me and the
other thing that greatly enticed me was
the documentary subject it's about the
proposed film Superman lives directed by
Tim Burton original script by Kevin
Smith starring Nicolas Cage as Superman
the greatest living human being on earth
all jokes aside though I have a
fascination with Nicolas Cage I don't
know what it is he's amazing even in a
terrible garbage movie Nicolas Cage
makes it awesome somehow except for Left
Behind my least favorite movie of last
year that movie just needs to be left
behind and just to get this out of your
brain I'm not gonna be biased just
because I know Snape and we got along
and he's a cool guy and we're buddies he
told me he was like I want you to review
this movie I want you to review it I was
like are you sure you want me to review
and he's like yeah I want you to review
I was like I'm gonna be honest he was
like yeah I want you to be honest I was
like awesome I'm gonna be honest but I
got to say I'm pretty relieved because I
watched a documentary and it is a damn
interesting and fun and fascinating
documentary so I do not have to take a
poo on Schnepp I was really afraid of
that I don't have to because I really
enjoyed this documentary now the thing I
loved about it is the fact that it
really puts you in the mind of Smith and
Burton and what these guys were trying
to cook up together you really have a
good sense of the concept of this movie
and you really recognize the fact that
this movie would have been insane it
would have been extremely different from
Superman's Lord would have been
absolutely positively a Tim Burton
Superman movie and as you watch the
documentary you wonder what this have
been a good thing or a bad thing yes it
would have been crazy and really strange
and weird and totally different and
unique but it also could have taken a
giant dump all over Superman's fans
around
world for being too different now one of
the reasons this documentary has
uncovered for the fact that it was so
different is John Peters now this man is
a notorious producer it was originally a
hairdresser he's now a producer and in
some strange way he's become the villain
of this documentary because people who
are being interviewed by snip all over
the place have these things to say about
John Peters that are not flattering
Kevin Smith says outright yeah he didn't
want me to have Superman flying he
wanted there to be a giant spider he
wanted all these crazy things he didn't
want Superman to have this or Superman
to do that first off he didn't want
Superman to fly Wow I mean that's
terrible that's a horrible idea
gratefully Kevin Smith is like uh uh I
don't know about that and Tim Burton was
like I don't know about that I'm sure
that idea would not have stuck but the
point is that John Peters is a very
interesting individual and I like the
fact that snap doesn't outright say it
in the documentary he does a really
clever way of editing together
everyone's pieces and then going back to
John Peters who's almost in a way trying
to provide a rebuttal of some kind to
the things that the other concept
artists and writers have said about him
and that's by far one of the most
fascinating elements of this documentary
the other thing that I really liked
about it is the fact that it kind of has
something to say about the internet and
the way we have this instant gut
reaction to an image this is the image
of Nicolas Cage that went around the
internet
it was crazy everyone was like wow thank
goodness that Superman lives did not
happen that was a terribly time
photograph of a very early costume
fitting that should not have been
released cages in mid blink he looks
like he's high it's just a terrible
snapshot this photo the final image of
Nicolas Cage in his suit is what people
probably should have seen because that
actually looks pretty damn good like I
know Nicholas Cage gets a lot of flack
nowadays but you got to remember in the
90s he had just won an Oscar he was
coming off of that Oscar win this could
have been really interesting and very
different and I like the way the doc
explored that sort of group mentality
the internet can sort of hoard on
something without actually thinking
beyond just one photograph know one
thing about the documentary that was
disappointing to me was that I was
looking forward to actually kind of
understanding what Superman lives would
have been as
movie beginning a middle and an end
story plot points things that allow you
to actually see what the film would have
been like and even though I just watched
a documentary about the proposed film I
have a great idea of concept art and
images and various ideas but I have
virtually no idea what the movie was
actually going to be like from beginning
to end I have no idea how I was going to
start I don't know how it was going to
end I do know that Superman was going to
be killed similar to the doomsday Ark he
come back with a black suit just like
the doomsday Ark but that's really all I
know I know a lot of concept art and
images I don't really know what the film
would have actually been like I have a
good idea of the strangeness and the
uniqueness of it and that was a little
disappointing to me because I still
actually cannot explain how Superman
lives would have played as a movie even
though I just watched a documentary
about it but still as a Superman fan as
someone who grew up loving the
Christopher Reeve films and grew up
loving the animated series from the 90s
and someone who is fascinated by Nicolas
Cage and does like Tim Burton's Batman
films I'm very interested in seeing what
this film could have been I'm also a big
fan of Kevin Smith and so it's cool to
hear their stories about this film even
though it doesn't get quite as
passionate or quite as under the surface
as I would have liked I'm going to give
the death of Superman lives what
happened a b-plus
guy's his doc is available right now for
digital download or you can order the
blu-ray or DVD from his site which I
have linked in the description below if
you'd like to check it out thank you so
much as always for watching guys and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes